Why Figure Skaters Don't Seem Dizzy After
Spinning
Dizziness is controlled by the vestibular
system in your upper inner ear.
Within the vestibular system, there are three
canals that contain fluid called endolymph,
as well as sensory nerve cells that look sort
of like little hairs.
When you move your head, the endolymph resists
change in motion and lags behind, stimulating
the nerve cells.
Those cells send messages to the brain, telling
it which way the head moved.
Now, when you spin, the endolymph lags behind
at first, but then moves at the same rate
that you’re spinning around.
When you stop, the endolymph resists change
in motion again, and keeps going for a while.
This sends a message to your brain that your
head is still spinning even if it isn’t,
resulting in the dizzy feeling.
The endolymph slows down eventually, making
you feel normal again.
Dancers and figure skaters have captivated
audiences by spinning around and around on
a fixed point.
Afterwards, they’ll often leap straight
into another move.
Part of the reason this is so interesting
to the people watching is that many people
can’t understand how they could possibly
remain standing without so much as a wobble
after spinning around so much, let alone leaping
into another move.
Don’t they get dizzy?
Dancers tend to get around this problem by
keeping their eyes locked on a fixed point
and whipping their heads around when their
neck can’t turn any more.
The result?
While the rest of their bodies are spinning,
their eyes trick the brain into feeling like
they’re standing still.
In this case, the endolymph doesn’t have
a chance to move around and alert the nerve
cells to tell the brain that the head is spinning.
So, the same principle should apply to figure
skaters too, right?
With the help of the ice, figure skaters are
able to spin at much greater speeds than dancers
can, which means this method isn’t really
safe to practice in these high speed rotations.
They will stare at a fixed point at the end
of each spin move, but they typically don’t
whip their heads around continually during
it, as this could cause injury to their necks
at the rotational speeds they achieve.
Because of this, they aren’t easily able
to trick their brain as well into thinking
the head isn’t moving at all.
So how do they do it after these high speed
spins?
The answer is the somewhat anti-climactic,
but perhaps more impressive, “they just
get used to it.”
Figure skaters do typically get a little dizzy,
but a lot of training means they are usually
able to ignore the sensation and carry on
as normal, without the audience ever noticing.
The beginner figure skater will start off
doing just one or two rotations per spin and
slowly work up to more.
They also start out with “easier” spins
before trying out the more dizzying variations.
With years of practice, they are able to work
past the sensation of dizziness so that it
doesn’t upset their routine.
While you might have trouble walking in a
straight line after a few spins, they have
trained themselves to essentially “fake
it.”
As Olympic Gold figure skater Evan Lysacek
explains,
Oh, you definitely get dizzy, but your body
learns to build a tolerance for it.
It’s like when you go upside down on a really
fast roller coaster, you’re going too quickly
to realize you’re upside down.
So I guess, when you’re going so fast that
everything’s a blur, you don’t get as
dizzy as if you are spinning more slowly and
see specific objects going by, if that makes
any sense.
There are tricks other than “spotting”
that coaches will teach their pupils as well.
Breathing exercises between rotations in the
early stages of training help the figure skaters
regain control after spinning.
In addition, at the end of a long spin, some
figure skaters will incorporate a dance move
into their routine before a jump, which requires
more balance.
The dance move not only masks their temporary
dizziness, but also provides a short reprieve,
allowing their endolymph to settle back down.
Bonus Facts:
• Astronauts often get dizzy because of
being in a continual free-fall state while
in orbit.
NASA studied 1956 Olympic silver medal winner
Ronnie Robertson in an attempt to figure out
how they could help astronauts deal with this,
but they found that Robertson never got dizzy,
even when spinning 500 revolutions per minute.
That certainly gave him a leg-up on his competitors!
If you guessed he was known for his spinning,
you’d be right.
• Olympic skaters can typically spin so
fast it looks like they’re a blur.
How do they do it?
By starting with their arms and leg (and sometimes
head) out, and then tucking their appendages
in while aligning their head with their body.
This works thanks to the law of conservation
of angular momentum, with the skaters picking
up speed by reducing their rotational inertia
as they bring the mass in closer to their
body.
This could be a separate episode on its own,
which we may do at some point, but for those
curious for more detail on the physics of
this check the link in the show notes.